machtkampf in der union verschärft sich
die cdu führung will armin laschet als
kanzlerkandidaten die csu spitze spricht
sich einstimmig für markus söder aus
draußen kaum corona gefahr aero sohl
forscher warnen die politik vor
symbolischen maßnahmen und fordern einen
kurswechsel und spezialist für
schwierige aufgaben friedhelm funkel
soll als neuer trainer den ersten fc
köln vor dem abstieg retten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind wie
auch norbert lehmann für den sport
keinen chauffeur familie die kür des
kanzlerkandidaten der union hätte heute
vollendet werden können wenn markus
söder eingelenkt hätte hatte aber nicht
nachdem die cdu führungsgremien sich
einstimmig für ihren parteichef armin
laschet ausgesprochen hatten kam aus
münchen das signal der csu-führung wir
wollen aber unseren parteichef markus
söder und so geht das kräftemessen in
die nächste runde geschafft
bis zum nachmittag lief es für armin
laschet ganz gut
zwei tage und nächte hatte er seine
partei hinter den kulissen bearbeitet
selbst die die in den eigenen reihen
schon mal mit markus söder geliebäugelt
hatten stellen sich heute nach fünf
stunden beratungen geschlossen hinter
ihren parteichef das meinungsbild im
präsidium als auch im bundesvorstand ist
eindeutig es gibt eine breite
unterstützung für armin laschet als
kanzler kandidaten von cdu und csu
eines war heute in unseren gremien
erkennbar
alle wollen eine schnelle entscheidung
alle fakten liegen auf dem tisch die
probleme die wir diese woche noch zu
lösen sind so groß dass wir nicht mehr
mit unseren innerparteilichen themen uns
beschäftigen sollten
die cdu macht druck drängt auf eine
entscheidung und hat die rechnung ohne
die csu gemacht die parteispitze kommt
am nachmittag in münchen zusammen auch
markus söder erhält volle rückendeckung
man will hier mehr zeit und setzt voll
auf sodass umfragewerte es gibt eine
empfehlung für armin laschet
es gibt eine empfehlung für markus söder
und es gibt auch ehrlicherweise eine
deutliche mehrheitsmeinung in der
deutschen bevölkerung money ist die
union in so kurzer zeit in umfragen in
der wählergunst gesunken
umfragen sind nicht alle ist aber sie
sind ein deutlicher maßstab und sie sind
auch eine deutlicher hinweis darauf was
die bevölkerung denkt und wir können uns
sie nicht abkoppeln von der mehrheit der
menschen in unserem land
nächster schauplatz morgen die
unionsfraktion 60 cdu abgeordnete hatten
über das wochenende unterschrieben die
k-frage in der fraktion diskutieren
im zweifel auch entscheiden zu wollen
auf die stellten und markus söder seine
taktik der machtkampf geht weiter
theo koll in berlin ist es jetzt schon
wieder vorbei mit der harmonie und
einheit in der union die gestern noch
beschworen wurde ja das war auch gestern
schon eher eine klare kampfansage der
beiden harmonie sollte ja nur im
entscheidungsprozess entstehen in dem
sylter zugestanden hatte wenn die cdu
nicht wolle dann würde er ohne groll
verzichten diese spielregel hat er aber
heute 1 kassiert oder zumindest neu
definiert er meinte dass könnten nicht
nur die präsidien entscheiden sondern es
müsse viel breiter aufgestellt werden
für eine mitgliederbefragung reiche die
zeit zwar nicht aber markus söder zielt
ganz offensichtlich unter anderem auf
die fraktionen denn dort ist für sehr
viele abgeordnete und ihre wahlkreise ja
wichtig wie stehen die möglichen
kandidaten in den umfragen da also jetzt
gibt es nicht nur uneinigkeit über die
kandidatur sondern auch über die
spielregeln für die entscheidung welche
chancen hat er denn jetzt überhaupt noch
kanzlerkandidat zu werden ja die sind
eher gering geringer als bei lasche denn
hinter ihm steht die viel kleinere
partei muss jetzt auf eine
unterstützungs dynamik hoffen die
außerhalb der engen parteigremien
entstehen könnte auch deshalb hat er
betont er sei bereit sich morgen in der
fraktion einer diskussion zu stellen
haben wie laschet wollte das eigentlich
nicht der machtkampf wird jetzt breit in
die union getragen und die vielen
verdeckten unterstützer die sünder immer
zitiert die müssen jetzt aus der deckung
kommen dankeschön für diese erklärung
für den moment theo koll wir reden
gleich nochmal zunächst zum zweiten
wichtigen thema in berlin
die koalition will bundesweit
einheitliche corona regeln für alle
schon morgen soll das kabinett einen
entwurf für ein neues
infektionsschutzgesetz absegnen
für landkreise und kreisfreie städte
gilt wenn es so kommt ab einer inzidenz
von 100 nächtliche ausgangssperren von
21 bis 5 uhr
der einzelhandel müsse
schließen mit wenigen ausnahmen wie
lebensmittel leben und ab incidents 200
sollen schulen schließen und auf distanz
unterricht umgestellt werden
zudem drängt die spd auf eine
testpflicht für unternehmen aus berlin
britta spiekermann
es soll schnell gehen noch diese woche
soll das infektionsschutzgesetz
verschärft werden
doch für dieses eilverfahren braucht es
eine zweidrittelmehrheit im bundestag
die große koalition schafft es nicht aus
eigener kraft die union betont die
dringlichkeit und wirbt um jede stimme
wir sind in einer dramatischen situation
die intensivmediziner sagen wir saufen
ab wir müssen was tun
die epidemiologen sagen wir werden stark
steigende raten haben deswegen war
dringender appell an die opposition
lasst uns dass diese woche zum ende
bringen lasst uns dass diese woche
abschließen nach anfänglich harter
kritik gibt es jetzt rückendeckung von
der spd doch die opposition ist dem
widerstands modus linkspartei und fdp
lehnen besonders geplante nächtliche
ausgangssperren kategorisch ab hier geht
es um einen unverhältnismäßigen dauer
lockdown mit ausgangs beschränkungen die
unverhältnismäßig sind wir sehen hier
dass es nicht gerechtfertigt ist und
werden entsprechende grundgesetz
einschränkung ablehnen das ist mit der
linken in dieser form nicht zu machen
es wird also weiter verhandelt um
zustimmung zu einer umstrittenen
gesetzesverschärfung ärger gibt es auch
bei der geplanten tests pflicht für
unternehmen die union und arbeitgeber
sind dagegen die gewerkschaften für die
pflicht der bundesarbeitsminister ist
optimistisch es wird zukünftig auch ein
verpflichtendes test angebot für alle
beschäftigten in deutschland gebe ich
gehe davon aus dass wir das morgen
bundeskabinett beschließen werden es
wäre viel gescheiter die hürden zu
beseitigen wenn wir kleine unternehmen
sagen dass das ganz schwierig ist zu
diesem schnelltest zu kommen
doch die beschaffung zu vereinfachen
weiterhin bürokratie niedrig zu halten
das ist das entscheidende dabei morgen
im kabinett die testpflicht
wahrscheinlich dass bundes
infektionsschutzgesetz auf jeden fall
dabei geht es um eine deutliche
machtverschiebung zwischen bund und
ländern in zeiten der pandemie würden
nochmal theo koll dazu der zeitdruck ist
immens die widerstände auch wie viel von
diesem
jetzt steht überhaupt schon und es gab
am wochenende ja schon die ersten
gesetzesentwurf der gemeinsam von
vertretern der großen koalition
erarbeitet worden war
mir wurde heute nachmittag von einem der
beteiligten gesagt man sitze aktuell
noch an einer überarbeitung denn dieser
erste entwurf hatte ja eine ganze reihe
kritischer stimmen provoziert unter
anderem zur verfassungsmäßigkeit von
generellen ausgangssperren der
neuentwurf berücksichtigt viele hinweise
auch aus den ländern und soll morgen im
bundeskabinett beschlossen werden und
geht dann im eilverfahren in den
bundestag und vielleicht schon am
freitag in den bundesrat angesichts der
nach oben schnelle infektionszahlen
scheint allen beteiligten jedenfalls
höchste eile geboten
dankeschön für die information aus
berlin dem käufer das beim blick auf die
korona zahlen geht es im kopf zu
behalten dass wegen ostern und der
schulferien weniger getestet wurde
das robert koch institut meldet 13 1245
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden und 99
tote in verbindung mit rohit 19
die bundesweite 7 tages incidents ist
weiter gestiegen auf 136,4 der höchste
wert seit mitte januar
auch in der wissenschaft ist die
wirksamkeit von nächtlichen ausgangs
beschränkungen umstritten führende
experten für aero sohle haben einen
brief an bundesregierung und länder
geschrieben die menschen müssen
verstehen dass die eigentliche gefahr
drinnen lauert in geschlossenen räumen
da seien debatten über den aufenthalt in
biergärten und über das joggen und
radfahren kontraproduktiv volker check
hat mir damals im liegestuhl unter
freiem himmel in schleswig holsteins
außengastronomie ist das seit heute
wieder möglich 71,1 ist der aktuelle
sieben tage wert und das beflügelt die
landesregierung weitere öffnung
voranzutreiben
aus der sicht von e rosol experten kein
problem drg hat scheuch ist sich sicher
und der frischen luft hat sich wohl nur
einer von 1000 infizierten angesteckt
wenn ich die leute von draußen nach
drinnen treiben dann erhöhe ich das
ansteckungsrisiko deswegen lieber
draußen einen kaffee trinken oder
draußen eine grillfeier veranstalten als
dass sich die leute in den wohnungen
treffen
viele stecken sich in innenräumen an
weil ihre sohle mit saas kopf zwei
partikeln stunden bis tage in der luft
schweben wenn sich ein infizierter also
in einem schlecht belüfteten raum
aufgehalten hat kann er andere anstecken
obwohl er den raum längst verlassen hat
stattdessen empfehlen die experten der
bundesregierung einen kurswechsel
treffen den innenräumen auch in klassen
sollten so kurz wie möglich gehalten
werden
regelmäßiges lüften ist wichtig raum
reiniger und filter sollten zwingend
auch im pflegeheim und büros installiert
werden und dann natürlich mit möglichst
wenig leuten treffen je weniger umso
besser ja das sind so maßnahmen wenn man
das kombiniert dann kann man sich auch
in innenräumen rechts sicher fühlen die
masken pflicht beim sport im freien
halten die verfasser des offenen briefes
für eine symbolische maßnahme auch
ausgangsverbot nacht seien ungeeignet
denn viele würden dadurch erst motiviert
sich aus protest gegen die staatlichen
anordnung heimlich drinnen zu treffen
auf den heutigen tag haben viele
engländer sehnsüchtig gewartet knapp 100
tage dauerte der dritte lockdown in
dieser zeit wurde geimpft mit tempo und
erfolg die inzidenz dort liegt
mittlerweile unter 30 zeit für weitere
lockerungen vor allem bei gastronomen
ist die freude riesig pubs und
restaurants dürfen im außenbereich wie
der gäste empfangen
schon um mitternacht genossen viele das
erste break groß war der andrang auch in
den geschäften shoppen oder ein
friseurbesuch alles wieder möglich
positiv blickt die deutsche industrie in
die zukunft zum start der hannover messe
sein nachdem corona tief ein
aufwärtstrend erkennbar
auch dank wieder gestiegener nachfrage
aus den usa oder china die weltweit
führende messe für maschinenbau und
elektrotechnik wird in diesem jahr
ausschließlich digital veranstaltet
neuigkeiten zeigen rund 1.800 aussteller
zum beispiel im bereich der robotik oder
bei klimafreundlichen antrieben fast
ausschließlich digital so erleben auch
die studierenden seit nunmehr einem jahr
ihr studium wegen corona keine
gemeinschaft weder im börse
noch in der mensa wie sehr das zu
schaffen macht das hat sich heute zum
start des sommersemesters auf der
bundespräsident angehört henriette de
maizière berichtet seit vergangenem
herbst des franziska studenten an der
fau berlin
doch hörsäle ihre mit studierenden all
das hat sie noch nie gesehen
bücher abgeben bücher abholen ihr
einziger analoger kontakt zur
universität
man sitzt dann zu hause allein vom
laptop besuch dieses rahmens ist das
portal was wir nutzen und irgendwie ja
sehr einsam in dieser komisch zu beginn
des sommersemesters dank bundespräsident
frank walter steinmeier heute in berlin
studierenden für ihre solidarität in der
pandemie
doch er weiß auch gerade sie die jungen
die unser land für seine zukunft so sehr
braucht trifft die pandemie besonders
hart und trotzdem bestimmen ihre sorgen
ihre probleme ja auch ihre not nicht die
themen der talkshows und der inzwischen
zahllosen täglichen sondersendungen
verwaiste hörsäle studium von zuhause
finanzielle nöte
viele studierende wünschen sich mehr
unterstützung und beachtung von der
politik kämpfen aber mit verschiedenen
problemen einsamkeit ist nur eins davon
aber das also technische probleme ist
jetzt vielleicht banal aber auch das ist
ein großes problem
wir sind auf uns allein gestellt und das
also das was studieren eigentlich
ausmacht fällt weg doch die
universitäten sie warten nur darauf
endlich wieder die türen zu öffnen
in die präsenz zurückzukehren mit ihren
studierenden haben die stadt stuttgart
und die polizei in baden württemberg bei
der demonstration von sogenannten
querdenkern am karsamstag falsch
gehandelt damit beschäftigt sich derzeit
der innenausschuss des landtags ein
fokus liegt auf der frage ob der protest
überhaupt hätte genehmigt werden dürfen
etwa 15.000 menschen hatten auf dem
cannstatter wasen ohne masken und
abstand gegen zahlreiche corona regeln
verstoßen
kritiker werfen der polizei vor kaum
eingeschritten zu sein
weil er ein schwules paar mit dem messer
angriff und einen der beiden männer
dabei tötete steht ein 21 jahre alter
syrer seit heute in dresden vor gericht
ein prozess der viel zu klären hat als
tatmotiv vermutet die bundesanwaltschaft
hass auf homosexuelle
zudem war der angeklagte den behörden
schon jahre vorher als islamistische
gefährder aufgefallen christoph
schneider
er will im prozess keine angaben
gegenüber dem gericht machen
der angeklagte abdullah hat in der
viertelstündigen anklageverlesung
beschreibt die bundesanwaltschaft den
abend des vierten oktober 2020 an dem
abdullah h unvermittelt auf ein schwules
paar aus nrw das in dresden urlaub
machte eingestochen haben soll
thomas l stirbt später im krankenhaus an
den folgen der schweren verletzungen
sein partner oliver l überlebt abdullah
h soll denise nahestehen
nach dem ergebnis der ermittlungen ist
der angeklagte angehörige einer
radikalen auslegung des islam und
sympathisiert mit dem sogenannten
islamischen staates
es geht um mord an thomas l versuchten
mord und gefährliche körperverletzung an
oliver l
der verteidiger von abdullah habe räumt
die anklagevorwürfe ein
er hat aus religiösen motiven gehandelt
und er ist überzeugt dass er nach seiner
vorstellung zu diesem zeitpunkt das
richtige getan hat obwohl abdullah h im
prozess schweigen will hatte er in der
untersuchungshaft mit einem
sachverständigen der heute als zeuge
aussagt über die tat gesprochen ärgerte
sich das homosexuelle paar gezielt
ausgesucht um ungläubige zu töten und er
bereue im nachhinein lediglich dass er
zu schwach gewesen sei dass er nicht
beide getötet habe daran sieht man in
welchem extremistisch islamistischen
weltbild er auch mal verfangen ist wegen
dieses extremistischen weltbilds
beobachtete ihn der verfassungsschutz
allerdings nicht direkt vor der tat auch
das wird sicher noch im weiteren
prozessverlauf vor dem oberlandesgericht
dresden eine rolle spielen
mehr zu dem fall finden sie in der zdf-
heute- es wenn sie mögen
dort gibt es auch eine dokumentation zur
islamismus und schwulenhass von unseren
kollegen von frontal 21
seit dem tod des schwarzen george wright
bei einer polizei fest
hier gilt die stadt minneapolis als
symbol in der rassismus debatte in den
usa
nun sorgt dort ein weiterer tod eines
afroamerikaners für proteste der 20
jährige wurde von der polizei tödlich
getroffen als er bei einer
verkehrskontrolle versuchte im auto zu
fliehen
offenbar lag ein haftbefehl vor nach der
schießerei protestierten hunderte
menschen
die polizei setzte tränengas und
blendgranaten ein
george wright war vor knapp einem jahr
nur wenige kilometer entfernt gestorben
und jetzt fußball macht das
trainerkarussell in der bundesliga dreht
sich weiter und zwar beim
abstiegsbedrohten fc köln nach der
niederlage gestern gegen mainz
postwendend der entlassung von trainer
markus gisdol heute die präsentation des
nachfolgers friedhelm funkel der
spezialist für schwierige aufgaben
eigentlich wollte funkel nicht mehr auf
die trainerbank zurück nach seinem
rausschmiss in düsseldorf vor etwas mehr
als einem jahr
jetzt hat er sich anders überlegt macht
eine ausnahme auf der anderen rheinseite
bis zum saisonende für den inzwischen 67
jährigen sympathieträger ist es sein
zweites engagement in köln insgesamt
seine achte station als
bundesliga-trainer
die mission diesmal kürzer als alle
anderen zuvor und heike drei punkte
beträgt der rückstand der kölner zum
rettenden ufer sechs spiele bleiben ihm
morgen wird er sein erstes training
leiten in köln sagt man sei es noch
immer gut ausgegangen stimmt beim fc
nicht ganz der ist schon sechs mal
abgestiegen den siebten soll funkel
verhindern
morgen fußball champions league
viertelfinal rückspiele titelverteidiger
münchen muss nach paris und steht nach
der 2 3 hinspielniederlage mit dem
rücken zur wand
dennoch bayern trainer hansi flick
glaubt an ein wunder an der szene die
für viele beste mannschaft der welt muss
morgen in paris dieses attribut
unbedingt bestätigen
als die bayern im hinspiel nach 0 2
rückstand
durch thomas müller ausgleichen konnten
schien der weg frei für den champions
league titelverteidiger
dass es trotzdem dann doch noch eine
niederlage wurde konnte die unantastbare
bayerische zuversicht zu keiner zeit
trüben ich bin aktuell noch sehr
überzeugt aber klar nicht irgendwie
idiotisch überzeugt und überheblich dass
das alles ganz locker flockig von der
hand geht und wir ja sowieso jetzt das
nur abarbeiten müssen sondern das wird
ein ganz ganz enges ding morgen das ding
beginnt um 21 uhr in paris an dessen
ende man sich besseres wetter und
glücklichere münchner wünschen würde
das dankeschön russland bejubelt heute
einen seiner größten helden den
kosmonauten juri gagarin standesgemäß am
himmel denn vor 60 jahren schrieb er
menschheitsgeschichte ausgangspunkt auch
für erfolgreiche russische
weltraumanzüge mit einem auf geht's
verließ damals gagarin die erde als
erster mensch sei er sie von oben
kolumbus des kosmos nannte man ihn heil
zurück feierte die sowjetunion gagarin
aber auch die medien im westen
verbeugten sich vor ihm und seiner
pionierleistung trotz des kalten krieges
das wetter in dieser woche bleibt kühl
und wechselhaft zwischendurch gibt's
auch mal sonne die details hat gleich
katja hornuf bettina schausten freut
sich auf sie im heute journal um viertel
vor zehn
danke für ihr interesse wir wünschen
ihnen noch einen unbeschwerten abend bis
morgen wenn sie mögen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
knaben meine damen und herren gestern
gab es in regensburg noch eine
höchsttemperatur von 22,4 grad und heute
nachmittag lagen dort die temperaturen
nur noch bei 3 grad
dahinter steckt diese kaltfront die uns
in der nacht und heute über tag weiter
richtung osten überquert hat dahinter
lockerten die wolken auf und sie sehen
hier auch sehr schön dass es einige
schauer von nordwesten gab
und genau mit diesem wetter geht es
jetzt auch in der nacht weiter also
zwischen dem alpenrand und im
bayerischen wald fällt weiter schnee
oder schneeregen und an der nordseeküste
sind einige schauer unterwegs machen sie
sich auf straßen wette gefasst der die
temperaturen sinken auf minus ein bis
minus 6 grad und selten bleibt es bilder
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
meist bei fünf bis zehn grad am
alpenrand über schnee sind es nur zwei
am oberrhein immerhin elf grad und auch
morgen fällt noch schnee zwischen dem
alpenrand und im bayerischen wald im
nordwesten sind einige schauer unterwegs
sie sind mit blitz und donner verbunden
in den mittelgebirgen auch mit schnee es
gibt aber auch freundliche gebiete hier
zwischen der ostseeküste und berlin vom
erzgebirge bis zur eifel oder auch am
oberrhein in den nächsten tagen geht es
wechselhaft weiter es wird aber von tag
zu tag weniger schauer geben und es
bleibt recht kühl senat noch